nicole is so wonderful to see you
you know you're such a fan favorite this
was a sad moment to see you be evicted i
we just absolutely love you and adore
you
and when you walked out of that house
julie gave you some truth
yes about the fact that you know the
janelle was there to have your back
knowing the truth now how do you feel
oh man i i really feel bad you know
that house messes with everything that
you think you
know every gut instinct everything every
relationship
it just makes you question it and the
more people you talk to the more you
question it but i really really
feel horrible horrible horrible for even
questioning them but you know
hindsight 2020 i wouldn't have done it
but in it you can't help it
i know she even went to memphis and
tried to put nicole f
on the block for you uh who was the
person that ultimately made you distrust
janelle oh man distrust
i would have to say
oh man i would say the catalyst was
nicole
f saying to me oh hey nicole someone
because she said someone overheard i had
misunderstood that and thought she meant
janelle
she's like someone overheard you and
janelle talking about backdooring me
and i was like oh no janelle set me up
janelle wants nicole f to think i'm
after her
this is no good and that's when i
started
spiraling and believing like you know
things like kevin would tell
like oh she's roping you in don't so
then everybody's
comments and my own brain just it just
it just went
oh if you see janelle what would you
like to say to her
i just want to like and i did tell her
this a little bit before i left because
you know
right when you're about to leave you
have so much clarity because everything
erases from your mind you see things for
what they are
and i would just say to her like i'm so
sorry you're
a tremendous human being who fought for
me
from the beginning to the end and i
don't need to get emotional but that's
something that a lot of
people in my life have not done and it's
incredible to know that she's that
amazing that even
putting herself on the line and getting
herself in trouble with memphis she did
all of that to fight for me and she's an
incredible game player she's a legend
the fact that she did that for me is
something that like i just want to like
hug her for you know oh and this all
started with memphis telling you
the fact that you should go into the
safety suite you decided not to
do you have any regrets now i
do not regret not playing the safety
suite i think a portion of that is how
fast christmas did it i think if
everybody had sporadic times
i'd be like oh i could have done that
but seeing you know
christmas beat everybody with a minute
and a half i'm like oh i don't know if i
could have beat that
so that i'm not upset about um and also
because i will admit
it was somewhat of my pride you know
memphis
with all due respect likes to throw his
weight around and he kind of you know
stood up towered over me and was like
play your safety suite
and meeting the way i am being in
anthony the way i was raised i was like
no you have no right to tell me what to
do and
yes game wise maybe that wasn't smart
but me
personally i'm doing this just because
you say so good for you yeah and even in
your pre-eviction speech the fact that
you kind of
to memphis can i do that i don't know
what that is but you know what i mean
you made that moment happen uh
what did you think of his game do you
did you like any aspect of it
i personally do not and obviously i'm
burned obviously i'm angry because the
man put me up and got me out
so that's probably a lot of where my
bias comes from but
you know i trusted janelle caser but
then didn't or
at the end i wanted to tell off
christmas and ian but then i didn't and
again
i think that goes with god and intuition
like somebody told me not with like
something
told me leave them alone but something
told me i had to speak out against
memphis and i think the reason
is he showed me his character in that
game in that game not life
from day one to the day i left and he
was always
kind of disrespectful and kind of
dismissive of me and
oh puny little nicole you're not worth
my time and
that to me just to ground my gears and
that's why i need to speak out against
him
and say you're this hulking figure who
can win
a lot of stuff especially against me
fully and you're getting me out like i
think it's laughable i really do
yeah even his speech when he put you and
david on the block
i mean some fans thought there was an uh
uh racial undertone when he was talking
to david when i think he said it's a
grown-ups table now
did you feel that way or did he did you
just think the fact because we didn't
see the whole speech um
did you think it was the fact that he
just didn't belong in the all-star
that's how he felt about david
i would say there is a level of
disrespect there um when he made
david have not it was a very
disrespectful
i'm choosing it wasn't even like oh i
have to choose you because it was a very
disrespectful
you um and the nominations yes he was
disrespectful to me
and his tone i think yeah but he was
extremely disrespectful to david
and i don't know what's going on there
and i'm not going to make
assumptions about him but i do think a
large part of it is
these two are from the most recent
season they are not all stars they are
you know insignificant to me they don't
deserve to be here they're a joke
because they were only here on bb 21 and
i think
i think regardless of the reasons why
maybe because i'm quirky maybe
because of other things that i really
hope it's not but
there is a um a disrespect there yeah
and i love the way you pitched to devon
the fact that you know having all the
females it was so
good it was such a good try but there
she
yeah it was such a good tribe kudos to
you for doing that but there she is
using big brother as a platform to be
able to talk about black lives matter
for you to be part of a season where
there is going to be more of an impact
to society
what does it mean for you to be part of
that oh my gosh
you know it means the absolute world to
me you know
obvio oh gosh i love david with all my
heart he is my family for life
so i'm so glad to see him have another
chance that i want to see him fight to
the end
and seeing such a diverse chaos is
something that i was really happy to see
i'm excited
to see you know all of them play and
you know one thing that i was very
nervous about was my conversation with
devon because i respect her platform i
get her platform i'm right there with
her
however when you're on the block and i'm
sitting next to somebody who i don't
want to see go home i don't even know
how i would vote
and it's me you know yeah you know i
tried i did try to save her please
please please think of game we made a
final three
please try to view it that way but i do
hands down understand why
she made the choice she did and i
respect it and i get it and um
i am right there shoulder shoulder ally
with them and i want to see them take
the game
i love that and your game let's talk
about your game we saw a lot of tears
from you this time around
a lot of emotions as well at some point
some of the fans thought you were going
to self-evict
how did you think what did you think of
your game
in total and was it the best game you
played
um no i i'm i'm a very honest person i'm
a very open person
i s and it's no surprise i said it on
the feeds i said i shouldn't have come
back
i came back too early um and it's to no
disrespect to anybody in the house no
disrespect to cbs or the producer of the
game i
love that game and it's tremendous but
me mental health wise
i wasn't in my best state and i do think
maybe it was too soon or whatever it may
have been i don't think
i was able to play my best game because
there was a lot more going on in here
than i expected there to be
and that's why there's a lot more
emotions i cried more i
shut down a lot more i got frustrated
more than i ever have like in my life i
was angry
which is an emotion i don't get often so
there was just a lot that i was working
through personally
and attempting to process personally and
that did very much affect my game
and no i'm not proud of my game and i
don't think it was the best game i'm
very disappointed
no and tyler is now ahead of the
household
who are the two people you would like to
see up for eviction
okay who i like and who i think are very
because
[Laughter]
i would like to see memphis on the block
next to himself no i would like to see
memphis and probably like um a cody or a
nicole f
if them three see the block this week or
any week i'd be so happy
i think yes it's a game and
if you're rocking and rolling kudos to
you i will applaud
anybody who wins it i'm not like that i
can take everything on the chin
however as nicole the person i do think
a lot of people
not a lot but some people in the house
need um some humble pie
and i think those are maybe some of them
and who do you want to win i
want to see kevin win that's my final
two
i learned a lot about him as a person as
a game player wow
wow he is able to separate himself and
see everything for what it is and he
doesn't get emotional and he checked me
a lot he played nicole you need to stop
and you need to go play
so i'd like to see him win it i want to
see david sitting next to him that's my
ideal final two
and i have faith i have faith it's gonna
happen i have faith
the rest of them who you know that are
not in that alliance will
come together and get some traction and
take them down
take them all down take them all down
and the fact that you're not in the
house right now who should kevin align
himself with
uh i really really really really hope
that
i want to see kevin and david link up
like i really hope
that me and david being like me and
david weren't really
like a final two we weren't really like
aligned aligned but it was an
understanding that like i will never
come after you because you're david and
i think he felt the same way
so i would like to see him and kevin
protect each other
and kevin's very smart and i think he's
realizing things
i do think he's going to attach to
janelle encaser
but also be smart with the other side so
i just hope he's able to build that
traction and stay and not go out this
week
i think i know the answers to this one
but who do you not want to win
you know i i absolutely like i i
love everybody in the house but i adore
certain people however i do believe you
know ian already won
nicole already won listen they don't
need to walk around saying that they
also want an all-stars like
nobody needs that you know so i don't
want to see that again
and i no offense don't want to see
memphis win because i want him to regret
evicting me so i do want him to feel the
burn a little bit
um so yeah i want to see somebody win
who
it'll mean something to more than
pounding my chest i'm the best i want to
see somebody win
who could say look at me i came back i
fought and i won this thing and is a
good representation of the community
and not somebody like i said who's just
going to be like yep i'm the best piece
out
yeah would you be interested in a battle
back
opportunity oh man
it that depends you know that's
something i will be open and honest
i said it on the feeds i was really
anxious about it i said
i don't know if i can do this like i saw
my mental health deteriorating and it
was only two weeks
and i was scaring myself because
regardless of everything i went through
last season
i was able to get through 99 days and
here i am
day 10 day 11 thinking i don't know if i
can do this
so a battle back i was scared i was
scared to
be maybe in sequester again i was scared
to
come back into the game again and not
know who to align with again and that
was very fearful like
very scary for me and i would have done
it hands down because that's the gamer
in me
but i would have it would have had a big
impact on me and i would have been very
very scared um so you are up for it
i was absolutely it's okay if you have a
chance you can't be like
no of course i'm just a firm believer in
like my path and my journey and my god
so yes i feel like my mental health was
deteriorating but if there was a battle
back and if i want it i would know
that god has a plan for my god has a
plan for me and my path was to continue
then he knows i was strong enough
so that's kind of the way i was thinking
it and the fact that i'm evicted
and there is no battle back that's my
way of knowing i wasn't meant to
continue in that house and i'm meant to
find myself outside of it i love that
nicole what did you learn about yourself
through this process oh man i learned
that i need to get myself together and
i need to not worry about everybody else
and i went into that house
not trusting anybody but wanting to
trust everybody but talking to everybody
but not wanting to talk to everybody
ostracizing myself separating myself
from yoga sessions and workout time
and you know i left last season saying
you know i'm more comfortable i'm more
confident i'm a butterfly
and i think i'm still caught up in
focusing on what everybody else thinks
of me oh my god i'm going to look stupid
if janelle and caser are messing with my
game and i don't see it
i'm going to look stupid if this happens
i'm going to look stupid if i say that
and i just need to stop i need to stop
take a step back and i need
i need to work on me and i need to focus
on me and i need to
find a clarity that i currently don't
have
well you're still my america's favorite
house guest it's so wonderful to chat
with you
and i know we'll see more from you but
thank you and
hopefully get some rest now i know it's
time for sleep
i don't go to sleep go take a break
you